histoire qu'a déclaré jules césar
vous jouez avec nous on essaie de
réviser le bac après avoir traversé le
fleuve rubicon veni vidi vici
alea jacta est
au tampon raum aures ou bien les amis
j'ai eu de l'eau jusqu'au cou y
s'écouler contre les connaissions peu
plus peut plus nous voir jean-luc alors
qu'est ce qu'il a dit césar n'est pas la
salade à regret veni vidi vici
veni non attendez il a dit veni vidi
vici après avoir traversé le fleuve
rubicon jean-luc si c'est ça je reviens
à 0 on vient à 0 à bah oui c'est comme
ça voilà autant pour omar s est non
alors autant par amour est jean-luc
césar il a traversé le fleuve rubicon je
me rappelle très bien j'étais et je lui
dis déjà dieu bénisse césar ce que tu as
fait partie et il a dit le sort en est
jeté
alea jacta est machine s'il vous plaît
on revient à zéro il y aura des
questions revient à zéro euro
mais voyez comme un bo saba j'aime c'est
que le mec il m'a dit avant je vais
essayer de pas trop de salir
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
pas du tout